alors qu il y a deux ans il ya deux mois
que sortait son roman autobiographique
orléans un livre poignant où l'auteur
revient sur son enfance douloureuse et
sur les différentes violences que lui
aurait infligé ses parents étaient
frappés à coups de fils électriques que
j'étais enfermé dehors que je passais
des nuits en flip dans le jardin sur le
plateau de balances ton post il nous
avait raconté ce passé qui le hantent et
nous dire à quel point son frère était
un homme dangereux mon frère était prêt
proches de groupuscules néo nazis mon
frère est à internet il a fait de
l'hôpital psychiatrique
il a été droguée aux psychotropes
pendant de nombreuses années son frère
alexandre moix avait alors porté plainte
pour diffamation
mais ce vendredi le tribunal
correctionnel de paris a rendu sa
décision en relaxant yann moix propos
qui selon le procureur relever davantage
de l'injure publique que de la
diffamation il est avec nous ce soir
pour nous faire part de sa réaction
c'est bon là où
la pause
d'être là il ya six mois heureux
libéré j'ai quand même
vous avez tueur au lac si oui qu'est-ce
qu'on dit des sites et quoi les
conclusions en fait et je voulais juste
venir pour dire ça c'est que il ya en
france des droits liberté de la presse
la liberté d'expression la diffamation
etc ce sont des choses extrêmement
pointus technique et réguler maya une
chambre à laquelle je voudrais rendre
hommage non pas parce que j'ai gagné
parce que si j'ai déjà perdu dans cette
chambre qui la 17e chambre
correctionnelle qui s'occupe uniquement
du droit de la presse de la liberté
d'expression et de des procès en
diffamation
et c'est une chambre extrêmement
technique qui regarde si on peut comme
ça à accuser quelqu'un au débotté pour
rigoler sous prétexte qu'il a dit ceci
ou cela dans l'émission que j'ai fait
avec vous m'aviez gentiment donné la
parole à l'époque ce qui m'avait
d'ailleurs sauvé la mise puisque avait
un vote à la fin de l'émission qui
m'avait quasiment exonérés de mes
conneries 10 à 30 ans est bien dans
cette émission j'avais certes dit un
certain nombre de propos la partie
adverse a considéré que ces propos là
pouvaient être attaquables comme ça de
manière fantaisiste et cette chambre
correctionnelle de la 17e chambre a
regardé techniquement avec beaucoup
beaucoup de deux d'esprit
pratique si on pouvait comme s'accuser
les gens et ce qui est très important
savoir c'est que cette chambre là elle
est un peu comme le maître étalon qu'on
conserve vous savez de manière
préférentielle
c'est cette chambre qui parfois de
manière difficile ou dur nous sanctionne
mais c'est aussi cette chambre qui nous
donne la possibilité de nous exprimer et
si les pas de sanction il y aurait pas
cette liberté en france expriment et
donc je trouve que c'est très important
de savoir que lorsqu'on a pas quelqu'un
en diffamation ça demande beaucoup de de
discernement on peut pas faire n'importe
quoi dire que si vous dit quelque chose
ce soir on peut pas comme ça vous
attaquer pour au petit bonheur la chance
parce qu'il ya des mecs qui attaquent
pour tout et n'importe quoi il mais d'un
mec là qui me fait un procès bien cette
chambre là elle veille au grain celle
que c'est très technique qui pourrait
pas ça non mais c'est pas simplement des
propos désobligeants d'abord on peut
très bien dire que quelqu'un à quoi a
collaboré avec des néo nazis parce que
quelqu'un a fait de l'hôpital
psychiatrique ça ce sont des choses qui
ne relèvent pas de la diffamation mais
par ailleurs si vous voulez
techniquement il faut voir si dans une
émission donné dans le contexte donné on
a le droit d'attaquer quelqu'un sous
prétexte qu'il a exprimée sur une
opinion moi je suis prêt pour les procès
de façon il sera garant mais c'est vrai
j'ai recensé à moi je suis là un mec qui
a un problème avec moi il va pas faire
un procès il vient me voir puymoyen
message qu'entendrait soir c'est que
tout ça c'est très technique qu'il ya
des gens dont le métier est de regarder
techniquement à la loupe si des propos
sont diffamatoires la france n'est pas
une qu une cour de récréation géante où
tout le monde selon as bien sable dans
la bouche je suis d'accord et donc et
des gens qui regardent ça de très près
et on peut pas faire n'importe quoi on
peut pas accuser n'importe qui n'importe
quand c'est important d'accord alors
qu'est ce que votre frère voulait qu en
fait c'était quoi le but de votre frère
alexandre il voulait si vous voulez
grosso modo réparer le préjudice suivant
qui est que
il a raté des choses que j'ai réussi
c'est tout et il pensait c'est la
jalousie il pensait que c'était au
tribunal en pleurnichant dans un
prétoire que tout d'un coup on allait
lui donner raison c'est pas de ma faute
après tout j'y suis pour rien si j'ai
fait des choses là où il a échoué il
aurait très bien pu faire autre chose de
sa vie vous avez le sentiment d'avoir
brisé une famille où s'étaient déjà moi
je n'ai rien brisé j'ai suivi mon chemin
depuis tout petit quelqu'un a voulu
faire du ski nautique derrière moi ou à
devenir mon sosie c'est une pathologie
de laquelle je ne suis pas responsable
il ya de la place pour une seule
personne dans moi voyez j'essaye de me
faire ma place on ne peut pas être deux
en moi
vous êtes peut-être un sosie quelque
part cyril s'est pas servi dans votre
corps
dans votre corps seule une très belle
carrière dans votre corps
oui et pourquoi là un seul l intérêt il
apte à vous donner leurs rôles
franchement aucun
dans les ennemis votre frère a perdu est
ce qu'en tant que vainqueur vous avez
envie de lui tendre la main aux lettres
une réconciliation petit vainqueur de
personnes j'ai simplement la
tranquillité d'esprit de pouvoir
continuer la chose la plus ingrate et la
plus difficile sur terre pour moi c'est
d'être moi même c'est tout ce que je
demande qu'on me fiche la paix et j'ai
pas besoin de saisie d'imitateur de
cloner d'avatar j'avance hull comme je
le peux pour le meilleur et pour le pire
et j'ai pas simple j'ai pas envie
d'avoir un type qui mitent 24 heures sur
24 c'est un problème qui relève de la
psychiatrie et non pas des tribunaux
maintenant je ne tends la main à
personne pour des raisons qui me semble
évidente simplement je voulais
simplement dire qu'il ya quand même dans
ce pays une justice qui me donne pas
toujours raison mais qui est technique
et on s'invective souvent sur les
plateaux on écrit des choses qui
dépassent mais je voulais juste dire à
vos téléspectateurs cyril que tout ça ce
sont des choses qui sont extrêmement
pointus nous on peut balancer des choses
sur des plateaux des gros mots d'extra
est alors parfois on s'attaque je traîne
en justice je te dire mon avocat il ya
des gens dont le métier cette dix
septième chambre qui regarde vraiment au
microscope de manière extrêmement
pointus
on